let's start by drawing a diagram of what
we might call the eternal triangle
really there's Charles Babbage but then
there's this other well-known person
that we need to include in our story Ada
Lovelace and in the end among Charles
Babbage's many proposed designs there
was one for what really is the world's
first stored-program Turing complete
computer is the analytical engine the
only problem is totally mechanical let
me link these with double-headed arrows
and we'll move about this diagram sort
of keep it in view most of the time the
sources of material really I became
aware of these when I went to an ADA
Lovelace's symposium last December and
yes it's taken me almost a year to
digest it all and to prepare these talks
let's begin at the beginning and let's
begin at the top left of my diagram some
of you may recall that actually I did
mention Charles Babbage in a video I did
on why binary trying to explain why the
binary system came to dominate in
computers the heart scale automation
manufacture wasn't quite there in
Babbage's time and he moaned like mad
the invoices the bills he had to pay to
talking about the 1820s roughly where
this story starts and saying that he was
a very celebrated mathematician but his
big forte was if he wanted to actually
be able to automate the production
initially of log tables now those of you
at the older end of the audience may
well as high school have been taught
before you know hand calculators even
came in but the way to do
multiplications was to turn them into
additions by using things called
logarithms so tabulating log tables was
the most enormous ly important thing to
do
I've got here the log tables I used at
school and Stephen wolf from his blog
says that even he it was probably
younger than me did do multiplication by
adding together logarithms and then
taking the so called anti log of them
when he was a high school there was our
four figure precision log tables here
very ancient book I bought secondhand
ages ago
these are seven figure log table so
therefore yeah he looked up logs you
added the logs you turned them backwards
with things called ante logs and that
was the only way four years of doing
complicated multiplications so Charles
Babbage actually did supervise the
production of log tables as it were by
hand before he ever got interested in
mechanizing it so a lot of the early
Victorian log tables got charts
Babbage's name on them but he drove him
mad
because first of all there was a problem
of computing these log tables worst of
all and he saw very clearly another big
problem was getting them printed the
mathematicians who drew the map might
well have got them perfectly right they
handed them over to the typesetters for
printing and the typesetters of course
tried their darndest couldn't read the
handwriting and made typo mistakes all
through and just checking them was a
pain he came from a source of
gentlemanly background was not
fabulously wealthy but well enough off
to afford a good lifestyle during his
career at Cambridge he eventually became
the Lucasian Professor of mathematics
those of you into the history of maths
team followers of numberphile will know
that perhaps the most famous Lucasian
Professor was Isaac Newton himself and
more recently and very recently I think
where he's given up
they Stephen Hawking the Lucasian
Professor of mathematics at Cambridge
Charles Babbage was not our in my view
as illustrious as those two I mean
Newton and Gauss and people were just at
a level of genius way beyond most
mortals
it you know he was a perfectly
creditable appointment and like his
predecessor Newton oh boy was he
thin-skinned he couldn't take criticism
and what's more he if he was around
today he would have been banned from
email Facebook and Twitter already
he loved flaming people people who were
stupid not to realize the value of what
he wanted to do and even more the stupid
grant give us because he did get grants
to build these engines
there was no penny-pinching of stupid
and lacking in foresight and when people
said to him look Babbage you're your own
worst enemy why do you know this he had
a bright idea he would continue to flame
but he would write anonymously and of
course his writing style and the fact
that nobody else would rant on
immediately gave the game away yes its
Babbage again so this was the backdrop
then but he did actually draw up designs
for a general very general kind of hand
cranked engine that could do more than
just lock tables from mathematical point
of view it could be set up to do any
mathematical problem that could be
represented as a function of polynomials
we've done this stuff we'll know Taylor
series Maclaurin series all this kind of
stuff yes a big class of problems
including producing sine tables or
cosine tables or lots of others so you
couldn't say that this these so-called
difference engines of Babbage's were if
you like special-purpose computers
people at the time thought they were
totally wonderful but do remember
they're special-purpose they can do
calculations but only things that can be
expressed through sums of polynomials
think if you like for those who watch
the Bletchley Park series a bit like
programming the bomb whatever is the
settings on enigma today that's
electromechanical calculator the bomb is
a special-purpose computer it can do
wonderful things but they have to be
related to the settings for Enigma
machines the difference engines could do
wonderful
but only two things that could in the
end be reduced to the method of
differences so don't think these are
general purpose computers they're not
there you were in the 1820s which was
before precision machinery became
available driven by electricity that
couldn't happen till the end of the 19th
century and yet you needed not a few
dozen cog wheels that you might need for
a clock you know typical clock maybe a
dozen two dozen cog wheels highly
carefully done by precision engineers
and all this kind of stuff you needed
hundreds and thousands of these wretched
things and so the bills from the gear
cutting technicians to Babbage sent him
into a rage he then passed these on to
the government who were funding him and
despite all of this only little bits of
difference engine smart 1 & 2 were built
which he kept to give people demos and
the yells came from the funders when are
we ever going to see this with these
machines realized you want more money
Babbage you are joking we have now given
you at the end of difference engine to
first stage we've given you 17,000
pounds Babbage that is enough to build
two battleships two of Lord Nelson's
victories could be built for 17,000
pounds Babbage had not delivered but
like every bad software supplier you've
ever known Babbage had the perfect
answer to these critics whenever they
said that you haven't delivered it was
always tell you what let's forget about
the mark 1 it was not good anyway I've
had a far better idea here's my set of
plans for mark 2 and of course they
bought it between different send you
want differences engine 2 maybe a little
bit more money would cause it to happen
but when you started getting a whole
load of flack about not being able to
deliver Difference Engine 2 he had an
even better idea
let's forget difference engine to aren't
a far better idea from machine that will
far transcend only what can be done
by sums Apollinaris a method of
differences this will be able to do
basically an infinitely wide range of
computations not just different variants
on the same thing it's wonderful I'm
going to call it the analytical engine
of course it will need at least 10 or
100 times the number of cogs of the ones
I haven't built that nevermind it would
be silly to waste more money on
difference engine to when I've had this
great vision for the analytical engine
did different engine to ever get built
yes it did in the early nineteen
nineties his drawings and his technology
were absolutely spot-on and the curator
one of the heroes of our story here is a
guy called Doron Swade he got the
difference engine built at the Science
Museum
once you built one of them for the
science museum which you can see after a
request from Bill Gates and Nathan
Myhrvold respectively of course CEO and
chief technical officer of Microsoft at
the time they built another difference
engine shipped out to Microsoft
headquarters in Seattle then I think
sent out to the Museum of computing
history amount of view but the last I
heard is it's migrated back to Seattle
weather back to Microsoft or somewhere
else I don't know maybe it's some other
museum so when I did get built and what
Doron Swade proved was that the
tolerances that Babbage set on those
gear wheels how far were Father teeth
were about Milan were perfectly doable
and he I think it was built in the
precision workshops down the base of the
Science Museum but basically is a
wonderful thing you know what did you
need to do this properly answer a
computer controlled in order to get this
early technology working which really
wasn't the technology of choice for
doing this kind of thing I've just been
wondering if it's possible maybe to do
that with 3d printing now
you probably could you know I've never
thought of that
what if people put 3d prints and 3d
prints yeah so anyway that there's no
change to the viewers
yeah so here we are then here is
somebody who could never finish things
the next release would always solve it
the next release will always called cost
ten times more to defect than the
present wall which was already way over
budget he did have the vision and his
massive number of drawings diagrams and
so on were vital and they did work
however reverting back to the Guru Doron
Swade again let's just finish with the
following observations Charles Babbage
adorned his drawings with all sorts of
his own shorthand he was called a
mechanical notation he never wrote to
use a manual for it so you had to more
or less work out from the circumstances
what these little squiggles meant and as
Doran explained to me it didn't matter
too much when he was building Difference
Engine two because they that was so
close to other calculators which go all
the way back to Blaise Pascal in 1642
you didn't need to understand every
single squiggle you just could get the
idea straightaway of what to do not so
with the analytical engine which is far
more complicated is there going to be an
attempt to rebuild the analytical engine
yes and it's underway at Doron Swade is
in charge of the BCS specialists little
group looking at this and if it never
gets built it'll be built at Bletchley
Park I think is the current idea so I
asked doram I said well if I understand
rightly handle its Glens you've got so
many calls you can't handle cranky staff
the question Babbage is going to drive
it by steam I do hope if you ever build
a replica like that he said you can
forget any idea if we ever get this
thing built built and we're talking
decades not single years right
where I'm not going to drive it by steam
and also we really cannot make progress
until we understand Babbage's notation
so that's the state of the art at the
moment they're trying to understand some
of the really obscure things in the
analytic design which just have to be
understood before they can make real
progress
there are other things in here called
variable cards those really were to
stipulate where things might be stored
you might have a reader number card but
you would